these are reversed this needs to go here
nope not that
this needs to go over here
let's go over here Oops I did something
I did a thing
hurricane yo toxic fire strike Hunter
Daniel
angry pirate Ryan Jake head what's up
man
Brennan Beastie Trail Joey
got you Trail
what's up 1933 a kill DC Marvel hello
Harrison geeky first straight so
rocket is right here
I don't really see her
she's right here she's doing really good
what's up everybody
hello hello nerdy wave hello
what I don't see Mr Anderson yet people
are saying hi but I don't see them
yet but he will be here I believe
I actually probably should
Chuck my messages what's going on
everyone is this it
has to be Daredevil today right
I mean we assume right and
but you know
all right cool we can hear it I mean you
know
we thought Daredevil was coming last
week Daredevil did not come last week
but hey remember what I said I heard
episode eight so
this is that this is that episode
I need to check my messages because I
don't always check them
um
wait what
okay
I think we're good think we're good
hello hello hello
I I hope it's Daredevil day y'all
Winsfield I hope it's DD yeah it looks
like it's LeapFrog and Daredevil day it
does I I really doubt that they would
tease us
that entertainment tonight
um
oh
yeah I don't Mr Anderson are you in here
yet
do I see him in here yet I don't think
so
it would be nice to do
it would be nice to do uh
a watch party for werewolf by night
but considering that we have She-Hulk
and I have to get up early in the
morning tomorrow it's gonna be a rough
one for me I don't know if we can do
that for who's Thompson what's up man
I'm hoping I'm hoping to stared up on
LeapFrog I'm crossing my fingers I did
hear it was episode eight so
one what is
but we thought it yeah
when did they
they teased Daredevil in episode five
question mark
right yeah
but they feel they they choose his
helmet
I feel
it was episode five I can't even
remember at this point
um
we'll see I'm really hoping I I'm pretty
sure I just you know
it's not a sure thing I'm pretty sure
but it's not a sure thing you know
it comes out in 17 minutes let's go
ahead and get the Disney plus ready
nobody's sure if one night will be out
sooner or later here uh interesting Sue
very interesting I find it really weird
that Marvel releases things at different
times you would think
it would all come out in the same time
let us just double check to make sure
yep we can still see it
let me go ahead and play something from
it to make sure I can still kind of show
the screen
uh I am on the wrong browser that's
that is what it is I have to use Chrome
I remember now
so let's do this let's pull it up on
Chrome
thanks Marcus you're not wrong
let's do that now
so She-Hulk
okay we'll make sure it's in English not
Korean and we'll also make sure we can
see it now
we can still see it
okay cool cool uh oh two Jonah
well you'll be able to watch it uh
you'll be able to watch it when you're
out of school
Jake watching the way home instead of
She-Hulk
is what it is this is the Daredevil
episode though hopefully fingers crossed
I still like
a part of me thinks
a lot of like a part of me thinks that
it's just like
what if they teased it so we would hold
on for just one more episode
because it's like you know like if
if it doesn't show
like let's say they don't show that
teaser today of like leapfrog and
Daredevil
and they weren't in this episode I think
people would stop watching what if they
left it for the literal last episode
when they teased it today so after this
episode we could continue to watch uh it
would suck
Sue there have usually been fake scenes
in trailer videos which scene do you
think it's fake one and black panther
forever that's a good question
I don't think they're uh I don't really
know they're
a part of me thinks that they just want
to be very genuine with this movie
um
and maybe they're they're
maybe there aren't many fake scenes but
maybe there are
um
I would assume it would be something
around
Sherry and
I I don't necessarily think they're
they're fake scenes I think the trailer
is chopped up to make us think certain
things and like hear certain things like
for example in the teaser Queen raimonda
said like
I'm Queen of the most powerful country
in the world I've lost my entire family
haven't I
have I not given everything but in this
trailer she just says I'm Queen of the
most powerful country in the world have
I not given everything
or something like that but she doesn't
say she lost her entire family I'm still
also wondering
if that line about her losing her entire
family is is a part in time is that part
in time in that five-year Gap when
people are blipped and they haven't come
back yet because I don't think Sherry's
gonna die and if she did it would be at
the end of the movie so it's really
interesting that that line she says
well I've lost my entire family that's
an interesting line I think that's
probably during the blip because in
Avengers endgame it said sure you got
blipped so
I I want to say that straight in the
blip or that line could be fake because
we didn't hear it the second time who
knows
hey thank you Julie RC I appreciate that
what if there's multiple Panthers I
think there is going to be
um
maybe not until
black panther three
because Kevin feige did say the reason
that we don't have
a recasting for t'challa for Black
Panther in this movie is because they
thought it was too soon which means the
next movie it might not be too soon
so
yeah
yeah Julian H that's a good that's a
good call maybe because of the flooding
maybe they think they lost sure they
can't find her or something like that
maybe she goes off on her own maybe it's
just like t'challa right
um
you know he falls off the waterfall
people think he's dead you know that
whole thing so yeah
what's up Jeff like skip up
what's up
am I gonna watch Avatar
uh Joey you talking about the first one
or the second one I've seen the first
one and yes I do plan on watching the
second one
um I def I don't think uh poisey I don't
think that
uh sure he will be Queen
I think Quinn raimonda will remain king
queen or imbaku will become king
um I hey there's Mr Anderson
I am
I've heard multiple things so it's kind
of confusing I heard that I heard
there's a couple different things I've
heard that imbaku becomes king
but doesn't become the next Black
Panther I've heard that embaku becomes
king and becomes the next Black Panther
maybe they shot both scenes
or maybe they've purposefully spread
fake information who knows
but uh I think mbaku is going to become
king by the end of the film if not I'm
sure Quinn raimonda will remain Queen
I do think we'll get a new black panther
uh a new male black panther I think
they'll keep shuri as a black panther
but I think we'll get a male one
Katan I have a theory everything happens
since Loki picks up the space Stone in
in-game and went to TVA from that point
everything going on in the MCU wasn't
supposed to happen
uh I don't know
it's a good point
we'll have to see how they
kind of bring that together in secret
Wars I think that's going to be a big
thing
yeah I I think I think uh Jason Jada I
think they're gonna set up black panther
3 to introduce a new male black panther
uh Ray werewolf by Knight out of 10 Jay
janth
um
it's really weird because I I really
don't like scary stuff I don't like
horror stuff and even like Halloween
kind of gives me bad creepy Vibes so
it's so weird
but based on what I saw it's so good I'd
say
like a nine out of 10.
I I would say that Damian Warner thanks
for Super Chat how long do you think MCU
will last decades uh yeah I do I think
I
think
eventually they might have to reboot
you know
maybe they'll have to take some time a
few years off and then do a reboot start
over with the Avengers again but
It's Gonna Last a pretty long time
give Bucky a panther suit or a wolf suit
see that's you know I'm wondering if you
know Bucky's gonna show up for the
funeral it would make sense that he
would I think we're gonna see some
cameos but I'm not trying to you know
put that out there
disappoint people but in my mind
logically it would make sense that
people who fought with black panther and
knew him
would be at his funeral or maybe it's
just what kind of thing who knows
I'm reading like scattered conversations
right now ah Spidey fan for life I would
think it would be really cool to
introduce storm I think I've talked
about in a few videos by now
they could say that she was an ex-lover
of t'challa you know or just like a
really good friend you know
I just think given their history in the
comics
and the fact that Marvel is introducing
the X-Men into the MCU it would be a
perfect opportunity to
put storm in there it would it would
almost be cool if they just like showed
storm like appearing in the funeral
don't really say much about her but you
know
a girl shows up with you know white hair
right
it's like uh you know are you storm
I am hyped for Black Adam yeah I
actually am I think it's gonna be good
sadly I don't think it's going to be
like fantastically amazing
but I think it's gonna be pretty dang
good I didn't want to really enjoy it I
think I really enjoy it
would have came to conquer does a cameo
in She-Hulk our bit just well I would
not expect that
just like skip up didn't Ayo tell Bucky
to avoid coming to wakanda for a bit oh
yeah
you're not wrong Jeff yeah I forgot
about that part and Falcon Winter
Soldier
Sue that would be cool like it would
like maybe storms in the next Black
Panther and maybe they could tease her
in this one I'm just
they obviously don't have to follow the
comic story but I really like the comic
stories how you know they they get
married and they knew each other since
they were kids and they get divorced
because of the Avengers versus X-men you
know and the X-Men attack wakanda like
it's a really good story like the whole
entire Arc of their relationship is
really good hi Rocky will you do it
what you're doing you're not on camera
today
a little out of camera it's okay you're
closer to me yeah
yeah uh episode eight is not out yet
Steve Walters
I'm really excited for Neymar too
I think it's gonna be a good a a big
character too in the MCU good and a big
character
in the MCU man I am so tired y'all
I've been going to bed a lot earlier
lately
so
so these uh these late night watch
parties are kind of hurt me a little bit
more now
poisy you're mad at that that's funny
Here's the final episode out uh well the
final episode is episode nine and that
is not out but is eight episode eight
out no not yet uh six minutes
we shall see
you think Neymar will become an Avenger
uh I think he will become an Illuminati
member I think our MCU needs its own
Illuminati
so despite event for Life the tiredness
is real
Abdullah Italy what do I think Dr
dimmable cameo
and wakanda forever it's a good question
no I either think it's going to be a
post-credits scene where they reveal him
or it's going to be a mention of him I
don't think they'll fully like reveal
what it looks like or anything like that
huh the guy thank you for that uh Super
Chat I would love to see your Cami on
the MCU movie Just because we're walking
past some superhero I would love that
you know I mean obviously I would love
to be in the MCU I think it would be
really cool if they did like a free guy
thing
where they just had like
like superhero YouTubers and they kind
of did it in like um Miss Marvel you
know she had her YouTube channel I
thought that would have been a really
cool time to like put some real-life
superhero YouTubers like in the MCU I
think it would be really cool
yeah I also like to play a superhero but
you know I don't have that uh acting
experience behind me
I was in some plays and stuff like High
School
a while ago and I actually tried doing
acting for a little bit but that was you
know this one the only time ago
but thank you the guy for that Super
Chat uh
[Music]
uh Daniel D what would you know all the
theories and expectations that they did
he shows for me but it's your job still
living in their garage I appreciate that
yeah and you know
I with the theories and stuff it's stuff
that I actually think could happen right
sometimes
what reality is off often disappointing
that's that's the line uh I give you
there
but I appreciate that and I don't I I
understand completely
um it's what I like to do I actually
like theories kind of the most you know
like
I like coming up with theories the most
because in my mind I'm like this should
happen this should happen this would be
super cool this would be super cool but
at the same time like on the
we don't really know what all goes into
like the back end of things like
you know we want I wanted for Multiverse
Madness there to be so much so many
different multiverses right I wanted
there to be a lot
a lot of different universes that they
go through and I wanted like a bunch of
different cameos I think the movie would
have been a lot better that way
but we don't really know what it takes
to get the cameos to get the actors and
all that stuff you know it a lot of
stuff has to come together on the on the
back end movies are huge there's
thousands of people involved you know
and sometimes it's not realistic you
know in the back end for some of that
stuff to happen I still think my fist is
going to show up somewhere
just like a meme I actually think
She-Hulk should have mentioned Mephisto
at some point in time breaking the
fourth wall I think it would have been
hilarious
so
thank you Spidey fan for life yeah it's
to me the theories of you know a really
fun part of this because
despite what some people may think I do
read Comics
I've read a lot of them and I've read a
lot of the older ones the older stories
uh I will admit I haven't kept up on the
new ones so much
um just because you know I'm so busy
um
but I I I've collected a lot of comments
and I've read a lot of comics over my
life
um I grew up reading comics I've read a
lot of stories
um
and I like part of me wants to see these
stories come to the MCU
and some of them are pretty crazy and
pretty out there like it's kind of weird
that we haven't
seen like
like
Cosmic entities and action we've seen
eternity and it granted the wish we've
kind of seen the Living Tribunal but
it's like
I have we haven't seen them like fight
or like do anything or even like the
council you know of the cosmic entities
we haven't really seen that I I really
want I really want to see that I think
it would be and I think we are leading
up to that right the thing is there's so
much Marvel can do
that's just big and you know whoever
asked me you know how long do I think uh
them's using the last for it they have
so much they can do I mean you look at
the comics and how many years have they
been going right
uh there's a lot of stories and you can
always create you know a bunch of
different stories
nice Mr Anderson
I'm so sorry I know I did not pronounce
that right but thank you and I hope
you're doing well as well
uh the new score for Daredevil slaps
well I think I think it's out let's uh
let's refresh here
um it's out and it's called rabbit rip
it so this is
the Daredevil episode
here we go Mr Anderson
we're going to be starting this in five
four three two one
yes jayant I do think they should turn
some of their shows into specials by the
way we have started this is where we're
at right now boom
we are doing the recap right now
just to recap
she says previously on my see look they
showed a
hell did we what was his name Josh Lucas
I don't remember Josh
or is that his real name
they're just recap uh yeah it's totally
gonna be that one guy oh no that guy's
name was Josh is the other guy Lucas
what was his name come on chat
I'm blocking it up
She-Hulk cast I never can remember this
guy's name because I think it's like
three different names
Todd
Todd who said it first Marcus
looks like Marcus said it first Todd
Johnny you were second Johnny Ray was
second
Jonathan's his real name Clancy his name
is John Bass
yeah I definitely think Hulk Keane is
Todd all right so it's starting now
they're just doing the Marvel Studios
logo
I need to turn subtitles on
is
oh look
it's frog man
the guard frog
he missed he tried to kick him and he
missed
my name is LeapFrog
oh look there he is
Mr patilio
they just like freaking kick in his butt
oh
time to Ribbit and rip it and there he
goes
dude that's gonna hurt if you fall and
he's falling
he burned his legs all up
I deserve justice and compensations for
pain
so she can have to sue the guy that made
her
her suit
I think that's what it is
which is gonna be
oh it's gonna be the guy who made Luke
Jacobson yep it's him
so now she's explaining that she can't
take the case
foreign
he's not mad
come to an agreement with Mr Jacobson
let's fix this
how do we fix this
why isn't it let me move it what is
happening
it's locked
there we go
what can we see in the background
oh
oh he pierced
be pierced
my work is impeccable
I'm not trusting you after you just
stabbed me in the back
oh she told him to take responsibility
She-Hulk will never get another suit by
Luke Jacobson again
you greasy old Buffalo
oh she is pissed
see you in court oh
he called her a tragedy
all right and here it is
Jake it's not the best oh they ain't
court now they're going right into it
wow
is he represented himself
oh
who's Her counsel it's Daredevil okay
he's here
Daredevil is here
trouble finding parking oh his driver
got lost
Matthew Murdock
wait
who's this a-hole
boom
I'm a really good lawyer
the sokovia Accords have been repealed
interesting
oh
I feel like he's
no I feel like he's winning
judge agrees to Mr Moda
dang
jet fuel
oh
get off at least
oh man
that was an
oh
can we go back to you being my tailor
he's gonna say no
because I hate you now that's funny
I mean
I'm in Leon what's up let's go with no
one welcome welcome welcome
ah look is binary a drink
she is drinking or whatever
I hate it when people take the higher ed
I'm loving this dude Matt Murdock
insulting a blind man's clothes
dude I love Charlie Cox
I love this
a hunch
it rhymes with Rich parents
uh I don't know Sue I I think they might
sleep together because uh
she sleeps with a lot of people in the
comics
Hell's Kitchen they said it
hmm
I'm loving this so much
Jen Walters can use the
inch
oh
Jen Walters can help and the law fails
people and She-Hulk can fail oh or can
wow
this is so cool
this is so cool
it's definitely different personality
we're all feeling this ah Sue uh
Todd just text her
Tech bro with the She-Hulk fetish
are you nervous are you shy
ah dude you should have got the number
or not according to a
not according to sue
so she's meeting with Todd
an authentic wakandan War sphere
a million wow
trying to impress her with the
wow dude
your chump
that's so funny
why is he shirtless
so he he got
oh no
they want it back
oh
she did not want his one
I could tell that we're both feeling it
oh
weird
I'm kind of confused now what is
happening
what is Todd bot a wakandan spear
which is to be made by vibranium so is
he going to try to stab her
lead progress being attacked
definitely physically maybe legally too
it's my famous secret lair
who is he being attacked by
thanks barlas what up all right here we
go here comes the new oh here's the
exact scene that we saw today so this is
the who the heck is on this car oh it's
daredevil on his car
ah
dude this is amazing
that his blood look at this guy
dude
I love this
and he just jumps and he's how oh my
gosh Daredevil's so cool
and here we go
oh that was amazing
is she gonna throw a card in
dude
he's very very mortal
can't throw cars at him
oh she's She-Hulk clapped him
oh
she unmasked him
she unmasked him
do you pretend to be blind
hey Leon thank you so much thank you
super super appreciate that Leon Haley
thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you
oh you're so cool
so cool thank you so much Leon you're
the best that's that's awesome thank you
the gold devil
I'm Daredevil he said it
ketchup and mustard is your color scheme
Leon thank you again no seriously that
was awesome thank you
I'll leave a note okay I'm so confused
at What's Happening Here
oh
he's still making
he's still making suits for him
oh he kidnapped him oh
leap Squad
this is so cool
dude
I can hear their heartbeats that's so
cool
dude
this is pretty cool
I'm healthy dude Daredevil
I'm so excited for the series oh that's
a cool see
that's not how that math works
I've done this a million times
she said oop I'm pointing to myself
you don't ever do this
that's so funny he just dives off the
building I love it
she says that's pretty cool
all right
here we go
oh
you guys about to get jacked up like
horde
and just the ominous door opening with
no one coming through it
oh
dang
and there he is
and there it is dude
oh wow
oh
it's so good
and this is supposed to be like The
Wrecking Crew
here they are
this is so cool
oh she came and smashed him
She-Hulk smash
that guy have a tennis racket
oh and here She-Hulk
uh this is going to be bad for her firm
dude Daredevil is just jacking people up
don't you yell at me
they're freaking talking legal time
I'm a big fan of liquid
oh
no shame in retweet Ribbit and rip it
did he just like break his entire body
yeah looks like you did yep yep
we're even you're forgiven so you'll
make my gala dress
try not to get too bloated wow
and Daredevil's just chilling
oh thank you Elaine I appreciate that
to jump out the window broken no shame
on Retreat broke his legs
I like that she unmasked him and found
out who he was I really do
I was the lead superhero
oh Sue I don't I don't know you might be
in trouble
Sue
oh so you're in trouble yeah
yeah I bet you someone's gonna show up
and stop him though
I feel like someone's about to show up
sorry soup
oh sorry sir
uh I actually heard this was gonna
happen I was just avoid saying saying
anything I I could not I was not
supposed to say
walk at home casual
Walk of Shame he's got the shoes in his
hand and everything
fourth wall break
it does not feel like the episode should
be over
because he's because he did the Walk of
Shame and he slept with you
you said oh we're happy I love Nikki
she's awesome
oh
the next episode is the finale good job
did she just do a wolverine
thing
uh and she totally just teased Red Hulk
what's about to happen
and there's the famous scene that we've
seen
and now a bunch of people are about to
show up and try to
I like how Nikki is behind her
Nikki
uh her parents
mm-hmm
no Todd's there
and doing everything
what
that's sexist
Jennifer She-Hulk Walters
uh multi multiple
winners
oh Mallory one
what's like being a female lawyer
this is the weirdest thing in the world
there you go there you go hey pugs there
oh
oh
intelligencia's here
she's a [ __ ] wow
I mean
adults have sex that's not like
oh those were like a she just destroyed
like everything wow
did her anger get the best of her there
interesting
oh she's going after
she found one of them
they're all after her now
oh she's like angry and like can't
control her anger
interesting
is that really the end of the episode
that is so unsatisfying is there a post
credit soon
nope
no post-credits in
uh if Daredevil wasn't in this episode
and that was the ending I would be so
disappointed but because Daredevil was
in this episode it made it really really
epic and I'm okay
I'm okay
yeah
Matt's going to represent her in the
finale that would be pretty cool
this was really good
this was a really good episode
Daredevil made it a really good episode
um
he was in pretty much the whole episode
hmm yeah
hey Daniel yeah Daniel that was by far
the best episode so far hey rocket
ah thank you Leon thank you so much
sleepy kitty what you doing rocket
this was pretty great and I think that
means
well
I don't know if Daredevil's gonna be in
the next episode or not
because
he said he had to leave
I was curious because they're in
California I was like I was you know I
was like
why is he there
makes sense and they even like asked
like why are you there
definitely was a different Matt Murdoch
Sue
um but they did say that his character
would be a little different in this show
than he normally was and it doesn't
necessarily mean
that when he gets his show that's how
he's going to be
so
oh he's such
a good like even everything we saw from
him
is like great I I love it
yeah
now Lee prague's not the villain
yeah every every everyone or Lee
prague's not not the yeah
it's so funny that we still
it's literally the finale and we don't
know who the villain is
weird
like weird
yeah I
it's intelligence is is the villain of
the show but who is Intelligentsia right
is it Modoc is it Todd
who who is it uh I disagree
with the writing there so
uh Daniels werewolf by night in May 15 I
don't know it should be out now let's
take a look
it should be out right
but didn't come out today
no it comes out tomorrow day
um
I can't do a watch party for it because
I actually have a hockey game tomorrow
at 11 30 p.m isn't that ridiculous
11 30 P.M
yeah I guess it's not yeah it's tomorrow
night I forgot
yeah I I I
I don't like I don't like how
it was yeah it was kind of the same with
Miss Marvel like some people were
talking about in in the chat like
um
just we didn't get like
we kind of didn't even have like a true
villain in Miss Marvel
right because it we had like the group
but then
um at the end it was I don't remember
his name
Miss Marvel wasn't really for me I
wasn't super into it
um
the dude that she had a you know crush
on at the end was kind of like the bad
guy that was like the final scene and
it's like well he wasn't really the bad
guy right so it's like I'm I'm getting
kind of weirded out by that with these
episodes
oh with the series like some of these
series it's like okay like we need the
villain like that's it's a very vital
part to any plot
so they did tease Red Hulk
but then Red Hulk didn't show up maybe
she's looking at Red Hulk who who was
she looking at at the end was she
looking at us we should get into the
camera
Leon yeah her boss might be the villain
he is a villain in the comics he's not a
good guy
this is a great episode though
this this is a I mean I can't tell you
how much I enjoyed
seeing Daredevil again
yeah I agree the Ducks and this is what
the whole series should have been
it should and even like just her like I
didn't need any cameos but I wish it was
her smashing things and people I guess
I like this episode a lot and it and of
course I love Daredevil and to me he
made the episode and but I liked his
interactions with She-Hulk right
do I think the villainous Kingpin RC
morbin um
you know I thought that at first I
really did
I thought because Echo shot him in the
eye he could have used the Hulk's blood
to maybe maybe that's how he would
recover
and that would make him even stronger
I don't think that much anymore I don't
think so I think it's
I think it's Todd
and I don't
I don't it can't just be Todd right like
or he has to be somebody like big maybe
Todd turns into Modoc you know like who
knows like I mean geez
yeah
yeah sorry Sue I knew they were gonna
sleep with each other I had heard it
previously I just wasn't saying anything
I tried to brace you for it I was like I
don't know they might but uh but yeah
yeah Liam when you watch it yeah check
it out
um
yeah the wolvert Dustin I saw she did
she came out with like the hair brushes
and she was like yeah I was like that
was Wolverine I think I even said it on
stream I was like she just did a
like and they confirmed Wolverine in a
in a pre you know in
episode two
episode one was it episode one
because it was like man with claws gets
in Barbara right I mean
I think everybody hates Todd Marcus and
Mr Anderson I think everybody hates Todd
uh he has a slime ball and
kudos to the actor
for for playing that guy so well really
dare Hulk Israel that's funny
I think it probably is the leader
and I think Todd is working for the
leader John
yeah there were a lot of Easter eggs in
this episode
yeah I definitely think someone's going
to become a Hulk
with her blood
I think that's like what's been set up
now I'm tired
I can't decide like
I can't decide
if I think the later is going to show up
in the next one
happy hey thank you for that Super Chat
I love all the fourth wall breaks she
does that really adds to the show I hate
the episodes are actually short keep
with the great work bro can't wait for
the breakdown thank you so much really
really appreciate that yeah
um I almost feel like because they were
so short they should have just released
all the episodes at once and we could
have binged it
I don't know I wish they were longer too
or I wish they were all released at the
same time
Sue what do I think about Nikki I love
Nikki I don't think she's bad I've heard
some people kind of say that
yeah I feel Andrew ready I feel like it
has to be Ross and I I believe she would
know who he was right because of all the
deals with her cousin and everything
and maybe that's Red Hulk
but I also kind of think she was looking
at us right some people like who is he
who is she you know looking at
I kind of think you know
they dropped awakens Easter egg on this
episode
they had some it really really had some
good good Easter eggs here
they really did
or Red She-Hulk maybe Titania
becomes red g-hulk
yes Thunderbolt Ross the actor William
Hurt did die in real life but
and they could replace them
did she see someone though I don't know
let me see
it really looked like she was just
looking at the camera
but let's go to the end here
yeah
she actually doesn't seem like she's
looking directly into the camera
yeah I don't think she's like looking at
us
I think she sees somebody else
yeah
incomplete archives I know right the
Daredevil walk of shame
I know
thank you oh thanks for the Super Chat
oh like the little dancing thing
uh Leon thank you so much you're you're
awesome appreciate that
Lily McCulloch hello welcome welcome
sorry I didn't see that before welcome
thanks for being here thanks for being a
member two super appreciate it
Daniel I feel like she was looking at us
an embarrassment no I just like I'm here
hold on let me
let's pull it up
oh full screen
wait no go back
so like specifically in this one part
hold on
see right here she's she has this look
on her face
she has this look on her face like she
actually is
seeing
somebody right like she looks like
confused that she's seen somebody right
like
right she's like what like she has like
a confused look on her face as she's
looking she's like huh
see and then she's like she almost sees
I don't know does she look like she's
looking like directly into the camera
there
um
does it look like she's looking directly
into the camera
I don't know I feel like she's not there
I don't know I I
it kind of looks like she's looking
a little off Nikki the great thank you
for Super Chat you're the villain huh
are you are you trying to say that Nikki
is the villain
I don't know this kind of really looks
like she's
looking at somebody else
I thought she was looking into the
camera too but
I don't think I don't know
that's a hard one that that's
that that's hard that that really is a
hard one to to determine there
I can't tell I really I can't tell if
she's looking into the camera or not
of
yeah I know some people are saying she's
just looking at us like she's
embarrassed
yeah I I well here again hold on let me
show you this specific part where she
like
it looks like she recognizes somebody
whoops too far
right here it looks like she and
see how she Squints her eyes
I feel like she's looking at somebody
else
yeah I mean
right
see that that part right there
specifically looks like she sees
somebody and is like what the heck is
going on
like huh you that's what it looks like
she's going like huh like it's you like
you're the villain
like you it's you you're the you're the
villain
could be Todd it could be Ross
yeah Nolan wins thanks for Super Chat we
got a hallway scene hell yeah yeah that
was so great then we got TL thanks for
Super Chat what do you think will happen
in the finale I think a new Hulk's gonna
be made I think they're gonna use her
blood
and yeah
I think they're gonna use her blood and
maybe it's Red Hulk or Red She-Hulk
Titania finally gets her blood and she
obviously has money so maybe she
employed like hope King I don't know I
mean really it's like
yeah
the shadow catcher thanks so much for
the Super Chat and thank you for your
input don't think she's looking at the
camera I can't wait for the next episode
I see her thank you so much
um yeah man look I I don't think she's
looking at the camera I'm looking at it
here
and I don't like if she's looking into
the camera they would have her like make
direct eye contact and I just don't
think she's making direct eye contact
with us here
I really don't
uh
yeah I don't know
maybe it's Josh
you know Hulk King
uh
whole King is probably Todd
poking is probably Todd and I wonder if
he's already kind of like injected
himself with her blood
you know maybe she's looking at him he's
about to turn into the Hulk maybe it's
Ross and that's why she's confused I
don't think it's Bruce I've seen some
people like say it's Bruce it's
definitely not Bruce he's on some car
Nikki the great thanks for Super Chat
Nikki is with damage control but weren't
they like friends like from before
demigod thanks for Super Chat why can't
they just use the leader's blood well
I don't think he's like I don't think he
has enough I don't think like he is he
himself has been able to like fully get
the transformation that he's wanted so
like
I don't think it would be enough as it
is already
so
Leah and you're awesome thank you so
much I really appreciate everything
you're doing here it's really kind
they definitely toned down Daredevil
they'll be so wavy yeah they definitely
did
um but we knew that they were gonna do
that they've they've talked about that a
lot
um so so don't be like concerned for the
Daredevil show I think it's going to be
more brutal
I do think you know they they they said
that there are going to be more Hulks
and Captain America
um
so clearly there's a big connection
there and they did confirm the leader to
be the main villain it's probably the
leader
but
but they have to reveal Todd as a
villain right
because like here's the thing
there's like zero reason to bring Todd
back
and they brought it back and made him
very kind of at the center a little bit
not the center because obviously you
know Daredevils She-Hulk they're the
center of the show but like
they they let you know Todd is still
here right and then they put him at the
gala too which is
coincidental a little too coincidental
right
saw her
she saw him at the gala
yeah I'm not thinking she knows the
leader Gregory stalls like you just
mentioned yeah I don't think she knows
the leader
I don't know how much sense that would
make
maybe it's just like Todd waving at her
right
and about to turn into the Hulk
and then he takes her on or something
like that maybe it's abomination
who knows
maybe it's
no it's not Mallory it's not the other
lawyer even though she is kind of bad in
the comics
all good Leon I'm about to the stream's
about to end anyways because uh
it's I'm tired
Berkus Thompson and oh crap and the
credits they dropped another wakanda
and Namor looked at the map on the
credit I think Hulk King is Hulk cleaner
Red Hulk or Red Shield yeah
can you tell it's Todd that's what he
has like long hair though oh no he
doesn't
uh
I don't
so she so she turns
and which way is she looking I can't she
looks to the right so she's not looking
towards the crowd I think she's looking
like maybe back inside of the building
yeah so forward to her is the crowd
I don't think she spins her body let's
let's take a look here
she's still looking forward she's still
looking forward her body is not spinning
she hasn't yeah she hasn't moved at all
so forward is the crowd she looks to the
right
so the right is kind of
is kind of like inside the building a
little bit
yeah to her right is like yeah so to the
right is like kind of just outside the
building
so it's someone to the right on the side
hmm
yes thank you Leon I do know that
and chandrax hello
welcome welcome welcome if you love her
mad together yeah I mean
I mean
I know there's the this is the debate
right here let's do a poll
ack did these like spam adult craps get
in here how do I do it well
all right here's the poll we're all just
gonna vote vote is she
Hulk
a She-Hulk looking
at the camera
oh my gosh what is happening stop it
or the villain
uh how do I
there it is scope
go go go
Oscar Lopez thanks for the Super Chat
ran out of theater and SOC
iety uh that would be pretty cool are
you the are you who I met at the theater
watching Spider-Man no way home was that
you
it's not a bad idea I wonder I wonder
how many people would come to that is
the thing I don't know
how many of how much of the audience is
in Utah
what's the poll at right now I can't why
can't I see the pull
kind of close it's kind of close it's
kind of close
yeah
I'm still leaning more towards the
villain huh
I kind of think it's I I I think it's
Todd
Daniel the person she grabbed I don't
know I don't
let me see something real quick
at the okay here it is
so this is
I don't think he doesn't have
like super long hair because then we cut
to the guy that she grabbed
I missed it on
oh
this flashing is like killing me
no I feel like he has too long of hair
no
I don't know I I
see the see how long his hair is back
here
yeah
nope it's Josh Nikki the great you think
it's Josh
I think it's Josh hmm
I don't know I don't think he's in
charge
because he texted the person in charge
remember he texted hulking
so I'm not I'm not thinking it's him uh
rojin thanks so much for the Super Chat
just tuned in did you like the episode
yeah I thought it was fantastic
I really did
so do we see how long this guy's hair is
right here right like this guy right
here
I I don't think it's Josh or Todd sorry
I'm getting all the names mixed up I
don't think it's Todd because let's go
to the scene
yeah yeah right here like
his hair is uh is it long like that in
the back
it's I don't think it's I don't I don't
think it's that long
yeah it's not that long so I don't I
don't think it was
it's reasonable it's hooked out yeah
Chantix yeah
yeah I'm not just I won't disagree with
that
hmm
I'm thinking it's Todd
Ron panea that is
Fair Point could be her reflection she
could be looking at herself but no she
looked to the right and I'll and there
was just like open space there
I would love
I would love if
I would love if it's Harrison Ford
that's Thunderbolt rust
a lot of people think it's Josh huh
no I hope it's not pug I hope Pug's a
good guy I really like pug
I see some people saying pug I like pug
I don't want to be pug
huh enchant tricks that's funny
yeah
I don't know if it is too soon for
Thunderbolt Ross to return on screen
Xavier
Nikki how much for the chair
I feel like the shipping costs would you
would basically could buy a new chair
for it if you're just gonna end a seat
I think it's like antesty.com or
something they've got a few Marvel
chairs actually
thanks for Super Chat Nolan uh I enjoyed
what they did with Daredevil you enjoyed
it I'm glad I did too
um
yeah I
I'm not worried about the Daredevil
series I know some people are like wow
this isn't like the same Daredevil he
fit the tone of the show
you know
you fit the tone of the show
his his just the way he spoke as a
lawyer
brought me I just it's so good
he's like Charlie Cox Matt Murdock as
Matt Murdock so good I loved it it was
so
nostalgic
this was way more nostalgic than
Spider-Man no way home like seeing him
back because we saw him in action right
although the brick grab was pretty dang
cool
I
now it says now the poll 55 percent
think she was looking at us or yeah it
does I thought that at first but there's
that one part where she's like
right she like does her eyebrows she
like Squints her eyes and looks like she
looks at somebody and then a surprise
that she saw them
hmm
interesting yeah Daniel Matt Matt kind
of crushed it but I I really liked how
they interacted with each other it was
really good
I
I might do it another pull in a second
before I
before I go to bed to see if people like
the fact that Matt and Jennifer hooked
up
if it's Josh then I gotta take to the
next Premiere Nikki I'm not sure what
you mean by that
really not sure what you mean with that
so
I here's my concern
there's no main villain and there's a
finale lift
and we know it's not going to be an hour
and a half right we always hope that for
these finales right we're like oh the
one division finale Miss Marvel finale
they should have all you know hopefully
the finalities are an hour and a half
long or something like that and they
never really work out that way
yes Lily I agree with you that courtroom
scene should have been how they all were
in the show totally agree with you on
that one
uh Gabriel Carrillo
um thank you for the Super Chat first
and foremost I really appreciate it
Theory one abomination working with the
dodc
yeah
Theory two red Hulk made with Jennifer
blood through through Wolverine ooh
I appreciate where your head's at I
really do I just don't think they would
introduce Wolverine and shield
I just don't
it's way too big right
it's way too big
but I like where your head's at
I think I'm inclined to actually
maybe kind of go with both Theory one
and Theory two maybe Abomination isn't
good
right maybe it's all just a big show
after all one of the guys from The
Wrecking Crew was with
you know was that the the retreat
at a Mill's place maybe it is
abomination
maybe he's not so good and he's working
with other people
oh gosh Nikki yeah
I gotcha actually the next one is Black
Panther
and I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
make it
I think it's conflicting with something
else that I really have to go to
we shall see I really hope it's not the
same day or the day before
I think
is that why you're sad Sue because you
don't see Daredevil and black cat
hook up I mean there's still a chance
for that you never know
I think it definitely is going to
connect Captain America 4. they said
you know other hulks are going to be in
Captain America four
and plus the leaders the villain so it
makes sense I think overall maybe the
leader is in charge of intelligencia
because
he is in the comics a part of it at one
point
there's also Modoc he's going to appear
in Ant-Man quantumania
so
could be Modoc as modoc's part of
intelligency as well
yeah hmm
I I think I think I don't think it's
going to be the leader I think it's
going to be like Josh or Todd working
for the leader
and that's you know if she if she's
looking at us
she's looking at us on the camera kind
of just saying like wow like can you
believe this is happening like or she's
embarrassed whatever
but if she's looking at somebody else I
think it's probably Josh or Todd if
that's why she's confused confused
um
Nolan I'm glad you enjoyed what they did
with Daredevil there thanks for Super
Chat I think I might have missed that
sorry uh yeah I thought it fit perfectly
with the show I thought it worked well
and I don't think
that's going to be
the Daredevil we see in the show
all right well it's the poll is pretty
close but it is 56 looking at the camera
us
are you talking about the chair Nikki I
got a replacement
uh cage thanks for Super Chat appreciate
that
uh uh I can't tell if you're
Pickers Colossus or Iceman
either way I like it uh do you think the
world war Hulk thing will be a series of
a movie I hope it's a movie
I hope it's I really do hope it's a
movie
really really do
yeah it's a it's sad that we have to
wait such a long time to see Daredevil
again because this was so awesome
oh it was so awesome it was so cool man
it was so cool I freaking loved it
I freaking loved it
it was so great
hmm
and Chantix maybe you know
maybe that's kind of
the whole thing you know they're
throwing that kind of like realism stuff
Nikki the great oh the premiere yeah I I
actually I texted one of the people at
Disney because
sometimes they uh
they they don't really tell you when the
premieres are until like sometimes a
week before like sometimes it's like
super like right before so I haven't got
the invite to the premiere yet which I
I'm pretty much always guaranteed Marvel
Premiere invites at this point in time
so
I don't know when it's going to be yet
but I I texted you know somebody at
Disney and I was like hey do you know
what it is because I have a trip planned
I'm really trying to plan you know some
things and uh
I never got an answer and I I also said
in the text was like if you can't tell
me it's fine
because they can't risk that getting out
and stuff and so I yeah I don't I don't
know yet
uh Malik I appreciate that yeah it's
been a while since I streamed on Twitch
it's just it just takes a lot you know I
do YouTube every day and you know we do
these live streams you know I I prefer
to keep video games now like something I
enjoy to relax even though I'm raging
most of the time uh Daniel dude I think
episode nine finale's gonna be longer I
really hope so I hope it's at least 45
minutes
but I said this before I feel like we've
hoped that for a lot of other ones and
we never really got it so I'm not
expecting it I'm expecting like a 35
although what this one was
yeah 36 minutes long but that's credits
and everything like that
um
oh
yeah
uh Lily yeah I
I saw that I saw I I looked that up too
but I don't think anybody knows right
now I think they're guessing but it
really just kind of depends on when
Marvel wants to release it
yeah uh
I don't think dared I was gonna be next
episode enchantrix and I see some people
asking how to get invited to the
premieres
um
and and the premier being soon Kenneth
um
you know the doctor strange one I think
was only like a week before because you
know
people will talk right
people will spoil things like if you
you know the you know an hour after your
premiere
go to Reddit it's all there because
people you know people go and they talk
I wouldn't ever say anything because I
don't want
you know I
I want to betray the trust of Disney
like that you know so
you know it's it's obviously an honor to
get invited to these things
um
so I wouldn't ever want to ruin that now
how do you get invited premieres
you you know I'm a YouTuber with almost
a million subscribers it's beneficial
for Marvel for me to be there because
I'll promote it and that's really what
it is
um I am considered press
because I report on news and stuff for
all the Marvel stuff so I'm on a press
list for for Disney I also get
I watch a lot of stuff before it comes
out because the Disney sends me like
everything Disney and everything Hulu as
well I watch a lot of stuff before comes
out I don't obviously talk about all of
it but I'm on the Press list which is
how I get that now some influencers are
invited as well so they can you know put
it on their social media and stuff like
that so
um if you know getting invited to
Premiere is something you want to do I
think there's a couple ways to do it one
you can join fan groups like cosplays
and stuff because there's always like
fan groups there
um
then they get to watch the movie and
they get to kind of like wait in like
this blocked off section and the
celebrities usually come up to them and
stuff
um or you can you know try to build a
following
and you can do it as an influencer and
maybe you know maybe they'll want to
invite you
um
or you could you know
start a website or YouTube channel and
start reporting on news and stuff and uh
maybe one day you could be on the Press
list you know and not everybody on the
Press list gets to go to premieres
you know
so it's not just like you know like a
casual
thing right it's not just like a casual
like you can't just like a ask to go and
you know they'll say
uh yeah you can go most people are
either pressed you know working for some
type of Outlet YouTube channel or you
know they worked on the movie or their
friends and family of actors and people
who worked on the movie stuff like that
so
yeah uh
Dozier Mayes you are right they did
repeal the sokovia chords which is very
interesting very very interesting there
was a lot in this episode it really was
a great episode it was really great
Frosty that's a good point
sokovia Accords got replaced because Red
Hulk is in charge
she did tease Red Hulk remember she said
maybe it's a red Hulk or something like
that
the the
[Music]
like the the soldier people that came in
did seem like they had like uh damage
control weapons they didn't look like
normal weapons but let me
let me double ch
at oh yeah those weapons are like damage
control weapons yeah I wonder if you can
I wonder if it like
do we get a close-up at anybody
can we have to deal
I mean it looks like the dodc
I was tired 10 minutes ago how big
uh yes I do get a guest I I get a plus
one
no I don't think it's aim I think it's I
think it's dodc
uh I just do YouTube this is what I do
for work that's why
you know I've been very fortunate
yeah the guns look like the Miss Marvel
like what the dodc had in Miss Marvel
I definitely think this is the dodc
yeah I'm thinking this is the idea dodc
but uh
put his heck's in charge oh
hmm
maybe it's been another Multiverse for
these after in game maybe Sue that's uh
you know let's think but yeah Lily it
looks they do look like the ones from
Miss Marvel oh sorry you guys are just
watching me read the chat now
I am competent enough to
Sue think about me being uh
oh yeah me being you know doing YouTube
for a living yeah I'm fortunate
um
and I take care of my brother and my
sister and my mom too since my dad died
years ago so I'm I'm blessed to be able
to make money doing this and be able to
help out my family
I don't think it could be Justin hammer
I would love if it was Justin Hammer I
really want Justin Hammer to return for
the Thunderbolts so badly
so badly I loved his character
yeah that was yeah
yeah Malik uh you say Super Smash Bros
was getting a trailer but I think you
mean Super Mario Bros
yeah
enchantrix you have a you have a decent
sized YouTube channel
I can't remember Enchantix did we
connect
we connected in Discord why don't you
send me a message in Discord
we'll we'll talk about that
is Fred I'll kind of get She-Hulk
pregnant I don't think so yo can you
imagine if Daredevil and She-Hulk had a
baby yo
yo
dang uh Daniel Bucky's on the
Thunderbolts roster because he is
somebody who's kind of like messed up
with the government and you know
he's already like you know what is it
court ordered or whatever to you know do
the therapy and stuff like that
so
you lost my Discord how dare you let me
see if I can uh
find you
I found you
I messaged you
there you go
uh no not my server enchant drinks just
my personal Discord
yeah I know Carlos I don't know about
those
I don't know about those sneakers that
they showed I guess that was just a
a tease for
no reason at all I don't know
uh cage thanks for another Super Chat
curveball question
how far-fetched would it be to see
Deadpool and some Fox X-Men
like Colossus next major I don't think
it's too far-fetched at all oh well Oh
you mean like
the King Dynasty Avengers King Dynasty
uh
probably pretty far-fetched to see him
in that one
unless they Multiverse jump right
because it is about Kang and the
Multiverse uh but Secret Wars I I
definitely think you know we're gonna
we're gonna get those and if not that's
stupid
it can be great she dulk ethels
I'm tired because that really made me
laugh
I think Bucky could be the new Captain
America no it's Sam
Bucky's not gonna be Captain America
he's
funny is
they called him the white wolf
in the post-credit for for Black Panther
fused
um
yeah I think it was the the
um black panther the first black panther
post-credit where
they called Bucky the white wolf
and he never really became the white
wolf although the white wolf was a very
different character in the comics
um
basically in charge like the police
force wakanda
but I don't think he's gonna be Captain
America uh Chantix do the event
tonight's episode I think she may appear
born again just calling just her calling
Matt or something maybe
I mean there's 18 episodes there's
definitely room for it
so
no there's one more episode there's uh
there's one more episode yes Bucky could
team up with Sam and Captain America and
I I hope I hope I hope he does I really
I really hope he does uh but all right
y'all I'm very tired
um and I have to sleep and do a
breakdown I also have to finish my
review for werewolf By Night spoiler
free that'll come out tomorrow I really
can't
say anymore how much I loved werewolf by
night and I hate stuff like werewolf by
night but I I really loved it
I really do I really did
it's it's just cool it's just cool
hey Kenneth Colton you didn't have to do
that you've been I've been seeing your
chat all night but I super appreciate
that thanks for the Super Chat that's
awesome just showing some support love
it it was really special she Daredevil
bad connection you know
it really was special like I was I was
watching and I'm just like dude Charlie
Cox back that's Matt Murdock in the in
in the courtroom and also as Daredevil
like
it was so cool
it was so that was so cool that we saw
that it really was
uh Julie RC have a great night as well
well if everybody Malik Alex
uh I don't know how to say that qwrq
um
I saw werewolf when I like a week and a
half ago or something like that they
sent it to me
um Lily I'm still calling for
Abomination to be part of thunderbolts
maybe we'll see enchantric tonight
Robert B to Z I'm very excited Barton
everybody Brandon Malik Alex
ogre man
the nerdy wave
I guess we're saying goodbye I said
goodbye now everyone's saying goodbye
okay I I love doing these things I am
tired and it's exhausting and it does
take a lot out of me
but I do love talking with everybody or
you know if you're just watching I super
appreciate it and I super appreciate all
the the super chats as well I appreciate
Mr Anderson uh Mr Anderson remind me
next time you you see black panther
forever I'll hook you up
um Mr Anderson has a channel he'll link
it below if anybody's interested in
supporting him as well
um and yeah I I love that we can all
come together and talk about all this
stuff I think it's really really great
what did the poll end at
us
us the the camera
she think uh majority of people think
that she was looking at the camera slash
us 59 to 41 dang hey Nikki thanks for
super chatting appreciate that yeah
definitely let's uh let's let's let's
see what happens next episode so y'all
live stream next week for the finale
who knows what'll happen we'll see but
uh it's gonna
it's gonna be fun it's it's gonna be fun
I think I think it's gonna be good
hopefully hopefully it is good and we'll
see who the villain is so all right
y'all let's stop with the super chats I
don't want to miss any
um because I'm about to log off here and
the the chat is delayed so
if you post it in a minute I probably
won't see it so let's stop please
because I don't want you to waste your
money although I do really really
appreciate it
but all right
finale next week
we'll see
but all right as uh always I appreciate
everybody who stopped by today whether
you're watching chatting super chatting
appreciate everybody and uh again thanks
to everybody for support you're why I do
this or why I can do this I'm super
grateful I love you all and I'll catch
you all next week